You know that smell?
That's the smell of fish in the morning.
Moe, moe, boo.
Okaire no si moe, geese, and welcome to my fishing boat.
Where's the Mito stream that I record was web fishing over a
year ago?
I've been found over says, oh!
More fish.
More.
more fish I'm always itching for a fishing game I'm always
itching for a fishing game wishing I was whispering
hello everybody hi welcome in welcome in welcome to uh cast
and chill chilling cast Cast and chill.
Wait, did I get the name right?
You cast and chill.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
The fish.
The fish...
I hope they don't fear me.
Get to watch Mint and Iron Lung.
I want to go see Iron Lung so bad.
I want to go.
I want to go see it.
I kind of want to replay it though.
Before I go see the movie, it's a refresh my memory.
Good evening, country, Minto, and I booze like y'all.
Gotta say, the fishing hour on the lake has been mighty fine
today.
Some big old bears caught up in some wacky worms out on my
kayak.
Big old 10-pounders.
Yee-yep.
Minto, any interest in playing Rainbow Six Siege?
I saw.
snake will be in rainbow six siege I saw I don't even know
that game I don't even know let's go let's customize my my
guy real quick what is this like a sleepy cap no we're oh
this one's so cute wait that's like a little raccoon I like
this one though I've been wearing a hat it's kind of similar
to this because it's It's been so cold.
Thank you for your glorious performance on my custom voice
pack, Vinky.
Have some funs for the extra time.
Oh my gosh, Nicos, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
You might, you just might be my sister.
Will you marry me?
We ain't in Alabama.
Spent two hours shopping for Minky in a bag supplies, only
to realize I left my wallet.
An hour away and they don't accept tap.
Pray I make it to the bank.
Oh my gosh, Evie's, no!
You are upset.
Sounds stressful.
Please tell me this is a game where you are a podcaster and
you interview the fish you catch.
What would they say?
I think they'd just be like screaming.
They'd just be like.
Do they have white hair?
Oh, look.
Oh, cute.
I want to be a grandpa.
You know?
I want to be like...
I've been fishing around these parts for a good 40 years.
Hold on.
Let's go back to the guy with the beard.
A fear blonde is the closest we'll get.
Crack the guest list for your concert.
I can't see it live, but I'll be streaming in.
Cherik, be one.
Thank you, Marilyn.
When I was a TJ...
Teenager, I modded Snake into the original Rainbow Six back
in, like, 1999.
That guy was, like, 10 pixels.
Blub, blub, he whispered.
Whoa, we can get the foal.
Oh, my gosh, this is so...
It's kind of chilly, though.
We should give him...
Oh, life vest.
No, this is so grandpa.
Oh.
10 pixels of fun.
Oh, yeah.
Farmer John.
And I love we can pick our companion.
This is so cute.
Oh, that looks like almost a Samoyed.
Oh, Bassin' Hound.
Oh, I've always wanted a German shepherd.
Oh, yeah.
I think we'll go for...
This guy reminds me of Fox and the Hound.
Oh, he agrees.
Pets, pets, pets, pets.
Whoa.
Oh, that dog is huge.
Wait, I just realized.
Oh, here we go.
Do you have a favorite breed of dog?
I like German shepherds I think they're very cute I think
it's kind of basic but I love Samoids they're so stinking
cute too Corgi I love Corgi I love a she oh wait I think I
was supposed to press to fish look at the dogs cast your
line oh new
species discovered my cyborg ninja helmet?
How am I going to be one of Vince's fans and tell her about
Zanzibar?
Big dog.
Happy fishing boss.
Thank you.
Wait, hold on.
Can I go down?
No, I can only reel in.
Wait.
I wonder if someone's gonna bite.
I don't have any.
Oh.
We got a thread fan chain.
I can't remember.
Have you been fishing in your life or after life?
I have been fishing in my afterlife before a storm I catch.
Catch your first fish.
I have been fishing before.
Wait.
But, I'll be honest, I don't remember having.
This is gonna be a relaxing stream before we play out and
wait tomorrow.
When did you get ears?
Oh!
I've had ears!
I've had some ears, well, since, um...
When did I...
When did this outfit come out?
No, stop!
I don't want to get you anymore.
I think I'm full on fish.
So when I'm full...
Oh, I...
We can...
Return to dock when your storage is full.
Oh.
Just kidding.
An Ibu fishing trip.
If we...
Look at this.
This is incredible looking.
If we can fish in some place like this...
That might be the happiest ghost ever.
Okay.
My nana had a German chef when I was a little one.
Oh, we get paid.
Oh, howdy.
Well, hey there, bud.
I'm Rusty.
Come on in.
Rusty, I'd like your finest bobber.
All the gear is over on the right there.
Lures, rods, boats, and upgrades.
A whole shebang.
All if you need a hand or a good story.
I got both in spades.
Good story, please.
How much for a story?
Appreciate it, bud.
I didn't know that was a tip jar.
Well, where's the story?
Give me the story I paid.
I paid for your time.
Rusty.
No!
I had 15!
15!
Can I just reach right in there?
I just got back from Japan!
and finally watch it live, got a bunch of Hanamaru Obake
merch all thanking of you!
I love a Hanamaru Obake, I love Hanamaru!
Hands in spades.
Minto, that's me!
Back in the day, we'd use a chunk of burger and a sock
and...
Wait, what?
To get leeches for fish bait.
You could also just use your...
Wait, I can't tell if you're kidding or not, Kinky.
Tell me a story, VTuber.
Ugh.
The story is...
Uh...
Never give up your lucky penny.
Wait, that's like an advice.
What's a story?
I'm thinking, I'm thinking, I'm trying to think of one that
I've never told before.
You could tell me.
an old one too?
You've told a lot of stories.
I'm a bit of a storyteller.
I have told quite a bit.
New species!
Come on.
That guy.
Oh, sorry.
I'm blocking him.
Oh, he just barely...
He, like, grazed my... Oh, he's going back for it.
Oh, he just missed it.
Oh, they're all...
They're all in on my... Oh, there we go!
Blue gill sunfish.
I wonder when we'll, I guess if we upgrade our boat, will we
get more, uh, what's the word?
More space.
You know, I was gonna not have my hair up today because I
thought it might get in the way.
Have you guys seen the fish?
I feel like I'm right.
Oh.
I'll make it a bit smaller.
will shrink my twin tails for today you sure can spin a yarn
miss me too so how you guys doing how you guys doing I took
off my wig I had a big old wig on the hat needs to be bigger
oh yeah the hats not even blocking anything right are there
any fish over here?
Oh, here they come.
Here they come.
Wait, we haven't caught this guy yet.
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
No, no, stay away, stay away.
Stay away, stay away.
You're afraid of my cursor.
Yeah, yeah, see?
They're afraid of my cursor.
No, you.
Turn around, turn around.
I'm willing it.
Worked out today.
Feeling a bit worn out.
Oh, no!
I mean, that's good to work out, though.
Oh, come on.
No, stay away, stay away.
You, you, you, you, you.
Turn around.
I'm willing it into existence.
Oh.
We gave up.
I was being serious.
That's the easiest way to catch leeches.
Walleyes love leeches too.
It's the best bait for them.
No kidding.
Wait, where am I going?
Grandpa, stop.
Grandpa, let's fish right here.
Nah.
Yeah, everybody stay warm if you're, like, in a park that's
getting...
Oh, there's a fish over there.
Yeah, a new species.
You're in a park that's got a lot of...
Whoa.
Wait!
That's a huge guy!
Mint immensely loves...
Wait.
Oh, yes!
Oh, yeah!
No!
We did a bicker rod to catch that guy!
Oh, man.
It was crazy, wasn't it?
Alright, let's go home.
Used a fish to catch another fish.
Now we're thinking with portals.
Speaking of portal, I've been thinking about portal 2
earlier today.
So backing up a little bit more.
Last night we had like a meeting and like a Denzetsu meeting
and I got some more information on some times that I would
be...
That I would be away on trip.
Let's see, I like this guy.
Best for brown trout.
Oh, I need a bigger...
How much is a bigger rod?
and i asked for like suggestions of what kind of games so i
want to not only just stream while i'm away but also for
days that i can't stream if there's like you know maybe a
consecutive number of days or something to have a sort of
let's play that i can put up still rambler.
Grab a fishing license.
Grabbing a fishing license lets you unlock new waters to
fish, because the best lunkers don't hang out by the dock.
Dang.
Grizzly Ridge!
But, um...
So, but I asked for some suggestions, and someone said
Portal 2, and I was like, you know, that might be fine, but
a lot of people suggested Zelda!
Like, because I've never played, like, an Ocarina of Time or
Majora's Mask, I didn't have a Nintendo 64 and then I just
never got around to playing it when to win it came out on
the DS and everything too.
So it would be like a first time playthrough but...
Thank you!
I haven't told you that I've been housing three cats in my
garage to help them escape the cold.
When I become so attached to me that she grabs my pan legs
with her claws.
if I leave with petting her without petting her enough I
might try to adopt her soon sounds so cute but for Zelda my
thing was I don't know if I would complete the game I don't
know if I could complete the game before I before I leave
and then also I think I would have more more videos than I
would have um then I would have days that I'm not streaming
because I looked into it I was like oh my gosh this game
says it's like 25 hours to beat or something crazy hmm I was
like whoa
without chat's help well I don't want to be backseated
through it let's get
We already got the blue gill...
Wait, nobody can...
Oh yeah, wait.
We got the blue...
gill sunfish.
Okay, yeah, yeah, I thought so.
We already got that guy, so let's uh...
Oh, whoops.
Let's get this.
And then we'll save up for...
the Maple Scout.
Oh, I can upgrade my rod strength!
Oh, wait, though, wait, though, wait, though, wait, though,
wait, though.
We should do that.
Nah, I'm kind of...
I can't...
Be too mad about my trip.
Because...
It's a lot of cool stuff that's coming up.
But at the same time...
My trip was originally...
For...
Like, it was truly a vacation.
And then it got completely different.
taken over.
uh, by, like, many things.
Which is fine.
Like, I'm not, I'm not complaining.
Because they're cool things.
And even while I'm away, I'll have cool things going on.
So, you know.
Oh.
But.
There's water there's.
There's been like kind of, it's kind of has exploded.
Like I was even telling like Steiner, my manager this
morning, I was like, I never, ever get like opportunities
like this ever.
And now all of a sudden it's like, and I'm like, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa.
I'm like, I'm truly feeling the suffering from success at
the moment.
I was like, this is, I think this is actual suffering from
success.
And let me also say, because my, okay.
My trip was originally.
What am I?
Okay.
One of my idolosies.
Her birthday is in Japan.
January but she's been but for the past two years her
birthday shows have been in uh have been in March so I was
like okay they'll probably do March again this year and then
also another oh she she announced her retirement and I was
like well she's she'll not be an idol anymore and she said
that it would be in March so I was like okay maybe I can hit
two birds with one stone And then, my Oshi was like, my
birthday, we're celebrating it in January this year.
And I was like, oh, no, that's fine.
What about the other one?
And then the other one, her, she's doing the thing, the
graduation, and it's after CarrierCon.
So I won't even be there.
And I'm like, ah!
So my two original reasons for even trying to set up the...
trip we're totally thrown out it's so unlucky yeah it ended
up being a little bit unlucky but wait oh I'm full just
kidding I'm full I know I'm kind of like going for a smaller
fish right now but we're just trying to get our money up a
little bit yeah so it ended up like first of all it ended up
being that the events didn't work out but i guess it's a
good thing the events didn't work out because at the same
time i would have been so busy with all the work and then
also oh she cat so i guess it works out i love that you can
pet Your dog.
Yeah, you could pet the dog.
Sorry, Minto.
It's all good.
I'm just being a little whiny, right?
I'm just being a little whiny.
No.
Oh, my God.
Look how cute he is as he looks in the water.
Is this a good spot, boy?
Is this a good spot?
Yeah?
Oh, change the lure.
Oh, I forgot to change it.
I'm so stupid.
I need some cheese for all this wine.
Whoa, we're going deep.
We're going down, damn.
No, no, you're too big, I think.
Don't touch my rod.
Don't touch.
Don't touch my rod yet.
Or my line.
I always release back the fish when I'm fishing, but
sometimes the hook gets into their eyes and they get brain
damage.
I saw that, like, you can't...
Uh...
We got the smallmouth bears!
I heard that, like, even the catching fish and releasing
them?
I guess it depends on... how...
um...
how they're caught, but I heard that they just don't also
survive.
Is that true?
It depends on the species of fish.
I see.
It depends on the fish.
Oh, wait, no, this side.
I do this side so you guys can see.
It's depending on the fish and how they were handled.
So if I take my trophy shot, they won't live.
If I man...
Oh, this guy looks tiny.
If I manhandle him a little bit, they won't live.
What happened to my fish?
I thought I caught three.
Trophy shot is deadly to fish.
That's so sad.
Come on, big boy.
Don't you want a taste?
Don't you want a taste of my lure?
They swallow the hook.
Oh my gosh, it's so sad.
Well, we're selling these fish.
So I guess it doesn't matter.
I suppose it doesn't really matter, because we know that
they are dead dead.
I wonder what you do with these guys.
I gutted one that had, like, two extra hooks inside.
Holy moly.
Eight!
Oh, nine!
Ten!
Oh, my gosh!
Nice!
Nice.
Oh, we're already halfway there to a new rod.
Let's go.
I want to see if we can go further out.
I want to see how far we can go.
I want to collect all the fish.
I want to collect every fish.
Yeah.
How are you guys doing?
How's your week?
Besides, maybe cold for some of you guys.
Okay, we're going to...
Oh, dear!
Cute.
Oh wait, sorry.
I'm totally blocking him.
Uh, how can I...
Where can I move to?
Here?
This probably works.
Been all right.
Yeah.
Just all right.
I right there.
started umma oh nice like the game or the anime um searching
for a job very good look at the size of this guy holy moly
honestly some days i'm just like i'm ready to just move out
into the into the wilderness like this and and be efficient.
I saw an art book the other day and can't decide if I should
get it so I'll ask my kamiyoshi if I should.
Well, I do like some art.
I do like the arts.
Oh, come on!
No bites!
Wait.
Let's try a different lure of fish.
aren't interested.
Yeah, but I want to move.
I wish I could move without...
Um...
Oh, there we go.
That's why I couldn't move.
Hope to let out the...
Huh?
I am.
Can I move now?
No!
It's not letting me use the arrow keys.
We'll see if I get somebody to bite in this time.
But you get what I mean, though?
Sometimes you're just like, man, time to live off the land.
I don't know.
I know some people really like living in cities more,
though.
They're like, I don't want to live off the land.
I want to go to the grocery store and buy carrots.
I don't.
Yeah, I don't want to Stardew Valley.
I want to
style queen RS Nation welcome to my bullshit black as long
as there's internet yeah yeah as long as there's internet
what oh there we go okay we can finally move again
alright let's try it right here that place was a bust
I think most people that want to fully off the grid don't
realize how much it takes to be independent.
I watched Breaking Bad.
I saw Walter White live in the cabin.
Julie, welcome back!
Thank you!
Oh, oh, oh, come on, come on, guy, come on, come on, guy.
My delicious lure!
It's super hard.
What would you say is the...
stop reeling when the fish is fighting hard oh okay my bad
what would you say is the most difficult thing of like
living off the land it's easy to take the conveniences of
modern life for granted that's so true though right food
poop how food living off the land staying warm and food and
water Oh my gosh, I didn't even consider that water wouldn't
even be a thing.
Oh my gosh, yeah, they're like, you're living off the land.
Oh, I think he's going for it again.
Clean water, I feel like, what?
You just boil the water, no?
He's fighting, he's fighting.
I'm not pulling.
No?
Oh my god, where is he going?
Upgrade your strength and length.
Dang it!
You need a filter.
At least Walter White had a pre-built cabin plus two copies
of Mr. Magurium Wonder Emporium.
Yeah, he did.
Oh, it is letting me use the arrow keys now.
I'll peek.
People have to dig a well.
I have to dig.
I might as well be digging my grave.
What the heck?
Here's my well and here's my pre-built grave for when I get
sick of this lifestyle.
City ghost.
I don't think I have it out.
I don't think I... Wait, I don't think I've cut out for it.
Wait, did I catch a single fish?
I really did.
didn't okay hold on let's maybe hey there stranger thought
you'd gone south with the geese no I just really suck at
this as fishing at this fishing thing bigger rod let's do
length and strength mint is a one-man army
have you ever had to pump water maybe yeah maybe we don't
live fully off the land maybe it's just a remote type
situation you could still I mean like I've heard of people
that live like an hour two hours from a grocery store so
it's inconvenient but if you have a small garden and then a
grocery store that's a little ways away.
And you still are able to you know, let's actually let's dig
up.
Let's go a little bit more to the right.
No Trader Joe's.
You guys know that.
What's it?
Oh gosh.
What's it called?
There's like a really fancy like um grocery store.
I think it's only in California.
Of course it is.
But like, they were, they sometimes like, I'll see some of
their things kind of go viral because it's so ridiculous.
They'll sell like a strawberry for like $30.
Erewhon!
Yeah!
Have you guys heard of that place before?
Well, clearly some of you have, but oh my gosh.
It's nuts!
Erewhon.
And they'll be like, haven't it's exactly as i'm describing
it's like so crazy high priced it's as long as you have
wally world you are safe i don't think i don't think this
guy likes my lure wait come on come on oh oh what the no
please stop taking fight
We might get him.
No, stop taking my lion!
Wait, we might get him, though.
We might get him.
You have to know when to...
Oh, dang it!
I was not reeling.
Maybe another guy will catch it, though.
These guys are aggressive.
They're a fighter.
Oh.
I wasn't even...
You guys, I wasn't even pressing...
What's the word?
Sure.
I'll take anybody that I can get right now.
Oh wait, we never caught this guy, a brown trout.
Nice.
Sure you could, Minto, but you'd have to cook.
I don't know how to cook!
California slander.
That's not California, just Los Angeles.
Oh yeah?
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Oh, that guy seemed interesting.
Everyone's okay with L.A.
Slander, though.
I don't know.
I kind of, I remember, I think it was last year, Anime Expo.
I think it was Matara.
She was like, we gotta go to Erewhon.
We just gotta, we just gotta see what it's like.
We gotta see what's going on there.
Um.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
We might get this guy.
Oh, I might have him.
I might have him.
Yeah!
We finally go.
Nice.
I'm curious what it's like.
Has anybody ever been?
I guess some people, if you live in California,
celebratory banjo.
Pretty much a Gucci Whole Foods.
Desperate to be scammed.
No, I don't want to buy anything.
I just want to go and look at the prices and be like, woof.
Yikes.
You know?
I once was trying to get, what's it called?
Like a nice bag for my mom.
I was like, you know what?
I think it was, I usually go to like an outlet mall and get
her like a, uh, what's the word?
Oh, what's the brand?
Oh my gosh.
Coach?
I usually go to like an outlet mall and get her a coach bag.
But I was like, you know what?
I always get coach bag.
I'm gonna go to, uh, to Gucci.
I wanna, you know, maybe I'll go get a Gucci bag.
I went in that store and...
Holy cow!
Reminder that supermarkets didn't exist yet.
And indoor plumbing and electricity weren't a widespread
thing yet a hundred years ago.
Wait, that's also crazy.
I kind of like, I like kind of stood in the...
First of all, there was a line to get into the store.
I had to wait in a line like I was on an amusement park
ride.
It was so...
is this you should have matara get you a discount on a roach
bag yeah it was like craziness i was like what the heck is
this so it was a line to get into the gucci store and then i
go in and i'm like i like i was like oh this bag is pretty
cute and i pick it up and i was like this is outlet gucci
this is outlet pricing and i kind of like just
You know, obviously the meme that's like, they don't know
I'm blank.
I was like in the corner of the store and I was like, they
don't know I'm poor.
But maybe they could tell.
I'm sure they have senses about that.
I'm sure they're like.
They're probably like, oh, this girl can't afford anything
here.
They could tell.
Yeah, well, it's not like, you know, it's just, I just can't
fathom.
them spending that much on a bag.
Any plans to play the Indiana Jones DLC I saw a demo for a
game called Roommates, Romance and Ringing Hearts, which I
think you'll like.
It's a live-action romance sim with cute...
Oh, I know that game.
I know that game.
Wait, we could play that.
I've been wanting to act normal, act normal.
I guess if you're already at a outlet Gucci store, there's
probably some judgment.
I'm not judging anybody going to an outlet store.
I am the person that goes to the outlet store.
But I'm meaning that the employees might be the ones that
are like, Yes, yes, you are at the outlet, Gucci.
Oh my goodness.
I am the one who thrifts.
Cheesecake!
Welcome back, thank you!
Come on, come on.
I think we got him.
No, no, stop fighting.
Stop fighting.
They are working there.
Why would they judge?
You'd be surprised.
Like, people that work in bougie places, like they have
the...
I mean, sometimes.
I'm not trying to...
What's the word?
Have you heard about the Birken shaming ritual?
I know about Birken.
in bags that is if you guys don't know okay so burkin bags
first of all you have to be invited to buy one of these bags
invite you you have to be invited you have to be given
permission to buy a burkin bag and then and then they're
like 30 000 like actual ridiculous the the craziest pricing
ever like and then you and then i guess from my
understanding is like you also don't get to pick what bag
you buy like you are invited to buy the berkin bag and then
they're like okay we're allowing you to buy this bag
You're just SOL?
What if it's a terrible ugly bag?
It's so bizarre.
It's so strange.
I'm gonna try this Bobber for a bit.
It's just like Ferrari.
Is that really the same?
There's a...
I think it's Ferrari.
There is a theme park that's based off that is like some
luxury Some luxury car brand.
I think it's Ferrari.
Survive the layoffs at work today.
Now I have to go to the office tomorrow instead of
finishing.
Oh, well, I'm really glad you survived the layoffs.
La boo bag.
It is Ferrari.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
It looks really fine.
It looks like a really good theme park.
I'm not even into cars, but I'm kind of like...
And they show kind of a little bit...
of like okay this game is frustrating me because i'm trying
to move to a different location and it's just maybe i don't
know how to play but it's in saudi arabia oh they there's
another theme park that opened recently in saudi arabia that
has like the world's like the world's largest it's It's the
world's fastest and maybe the largest drop in the world.
The Mr. Beast theme park.
No.
No, no, not the Mr. Beast theme park.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Actually, go back, go back.
Maybe we buy another... Oh wait, I think I wanted to buy
another bobber and...
There we go, thank you!
I think I wanted to buy another bobber and I said I needed
to upgrade my rod first.
Yeah, another bigger rod.
Oh, wait, this one.
Walleye and question mark, question mark.
Hmm.
I thought the Mr. Beastland was temporary.
Is it still there?
Is Haneda tickets worth paying extra for first Japan visit
instead of Narita?
I would say it depends.
on how much more expensive it is but getting to main Tokyo
from Haneda is way easier than getting to main Tokyo from
Narita and the airport is nicer it was just a month that's
insane that's crazy it was just a month what the hell I'm
Almost...
This one, I feel like we should just save up for the 8 plus
pound, you know?
The timber jack.
But at the same time, I'm also like, I want to get all the
upgrades, you know what I mean?
But Narita is named for Narita Top Road.
But Narita is bad airport.
You can upgrade your storage space too.
Oh, is it this one?
No, this is licensing.
My boat?
Is that... Oh, my boat...
No.
I can't... Oh, wait, here!
Ah, fish storage!
Okay, we'll buy... We'll buy so we can hold four fish now.
Thank you.
And then...
Let's go fishing.
You think Ferrari Land has a fer- Fer- Fer- Fer- Fer- Ferris
wheel?
It, uh, it does have, um...
It has like...
I can't remember what it...
It has like some weird observation rooftop.
And you can... I don't know.
I've been... I've like...
Wanted to go, but obviously...
When the hell am I ever gonna...
Get... Get to Saudi Arabia.
Ferraris, Ferraris wheel.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna switch my...
There we go.
Spins as fast as a Ferrari wheel.
Hold on, folks.
That'd be wild.
Oh, oh.
Yeah, come on.
I think we got him.
Easy.
Yeah.
I just want to go to theme park.
Ferrari world looks so fine but if they give me a free
Ferrari I'll give you guys a ride oh shoot I forgot oh my
bad I only say good morning when I'm fishing because that's
the only time it is a good morning right a free Rari if you
guys like the demo cars like in a showroom and you're just
like wow!
Car of the future!
When will they sell this?
And they're like 2,000 and 100.
And you're like, oh okay.
Sure.
If they ever, I know.
It's Like this is a car that we might have in the future.
And I'm like, this ain't the Jetsons.
Like, stop making cars that you can't produce.
You're getting my hopes up.
I dream of owning a K-truck, not a Ferrari.
Yeah, K-truck, so cute.
It's called a concept.
It's called a tease, that's what it is.
It's called a tease.
Thinking about test track, like the ride of Disney?
Oh, nice!
We got that guy easy.
Alright, let's head back.
Easy delivery co-stream.
I know that in the United States.
K-trucks are not allowed in everywhere because they're not
like, I guess.
They're like, if you have a K-truck, you will become an
accordion if you get hit.
And what I say to that is Vote for me for president Because
I will make Everybody have a K truck So then nobody will
Will have to deal with it Everybody can have a K truck And
then And then Nobody will have to worry about The really big
cars Flattening you being able to see you everyone will
accord in yeah what the keep going keep going mister you've
won my vote the goal is that every people think bigger
bigger we got to get bigger no no everybody just has to get
small small small
A K truck and an Adisoo truck.
Shut up.
Meet those super pack finds.
More like super packed finds.
Because I have lots of ideas opening this noggin, baby.
Packed with ideas.
Weeks of ideas.
I'm listening in the background and I swore I kept hearing
you say gay truck wasn't sure what you were talking about
them gay trucks oh my god wait what if in tomodachi life you
can make optimus prime optimus primal even even better i
might have just sold the game for
For...
Doki bird.
Minto of the lake, what is your wisdom?
Don't think.
Just feel.
Optimus pride.
Oh, oh, there he goes.
I'm not even clicking.
Holy cow.
These guys are nuts.
These guys are so nuts.
Yeah,
go back to my, go back to my boat.
Yeah, yeah, go back to my boat.
I almost just want to do upgrades.
Look, like, stop!
I can't even work with you!
Ah.
Alright, let that, let, let the lure drip again.
Never mind, it's not going down.
They have so much fire.
They really do.
How many fish do I have?
Nod!
Counting the months till I become a rainbow eye woo.
Soon, soon, soon.
Oh.
That was so clean.
Oh, I have one.
Okay, good.
I'm not reeling, you guys.
You say stop reeling when there's bubbles.
My hand is off my mouse.
They just pull that hard.
They just pull like crazy.
Like I'm reeling now.
And then I'm not.
Now I'm reeling.
Now I'm not.
And there he goes.
Okay, now it's a lost cause basically.
You are clearly reeling.
Reeling with her feet.
I know.
I'm just that talented, honestly.
Oh, we might have him.
We might have him.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on.
Yeah!
New biggest catch!
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, no.
See?
My hand is off my mouse.
Phil!
Thank you so much for the fantastic update.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Free Joe!
Welcome to Babu Shop!
Thank you!
Hold on.
Let's uh...
Okay.
Thank you, thank you.
Dang it.
Sometimes I don't want...
I want to move, but the game says, no, you must fish.
But I want to move.
I want to catch this guy.
I want to catch these guys here.
I think this guy goes after my...
What does the heart say?
The heart says...
Women fear me, fish fear me, men turn their eyes away from
me as I walk.
No beast dare make a sound in my presence I am alone on this
barren earth.
Come on.
Nope, I think it's a lost cause.
I'm giving up.
I'm pulling just so I can get it back.
I've never had much patience for fishing.
I think that means you're not old enough yet.
You know?
Were you influenced by other VTubers playing this?
I did see somebody else playing it.
But I was like, I just want to fish.
Let's go get some upgrades.
Let me pet my dog first.
Now we go upgrade.
I think...
I think old people have patience for fishing because...
Because...
They know that they're at the end stages.
I have patience for fishing because I'm dead and I have only
time.
We're at 86!
Hello!
Holy smokes, you clean out the lake or just the cocky ones.
I'm doing a good job out there, okay, mister?
I think we gotta do line strength.
It's fine.
I mean, we can switch out rods anyway, because this one's
also good for small, so we'll be using it.
I
guess I'm old and dying.
I mean, everybody's dying.
Except me.
Unless ghosts have like a...
I don't think they have like a...
No one told me.
Can I only be a ghost for a certain amount of time?
Are you going to eat the fish you catch?
What's like a good fresh water?
fish.
Wait, do these guys go for this lore?
Yes, they do.
Okay, nice.
Trout.
I don't think I've ever had a trout.
Oh, salmon!
For some reason, I always think salmon is a salt water fish.
Like, you're right.
Salmon have such fascinating lives.
Like, just the way... What was it?
There's like a weird there's a hold on like a weird disease
or something don't they switch can they salmon spawn in
fresh water they spawn wait hold on I'm gonna look this up
they're kind of both oh
let's see uh salmon I learned it about I learned it I
learned about this not too long ago.
Trying to see what it is though.
It's like basically they become like a zombie.
Yeah, it's literally called like a zombie salmon.
Maybe
it's...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's freaky, right?
Zombie salmon.
Hold on.
I don't want to I don't know if the AI overview was
accurate, so we'll just...
Oh, he's gonna fish all on his own!
Perfect!
Let's see, hold on.
Yeah, they get like...
Hold on.
Okay, they get like really freaky.
I'm gonna see if this explains it.
How do I... Hold on.
It says...
Oh, thanks!
Zombie salmon refers to the last stages in a fish life cycle
after they have used almost all of their energy to spawn
depositing eggs in a gravel nest called a red salmon swim
around for some time while their bodies start to deteriorate
and rot it's so crazy salmon life is messed up it really is
it really is thank you so much for the read that work thank
you thank you
it says during this phase male salmon grow extra large teeth
to compete for mating also during this time a parasitic worm
called the philobrothium takes up residence in the salmon's
brain where it's able to gain control of them crazy luckily
that's not going to happen our fish.
Where's the glitch face?
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, Darko, thank you!
No, well, thank you.
Thank you guys for all the gifts.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Guys, I'm not even playing the game.
I think we're the zombie.
I've been infected by worms.
No!
They have weird teeth just like you.
What's wrong with my teeth?
I don't think I have weird teeth.
Right?
I don't think I have I don't think I have weird teeth.
Wait, what am I fishing like?
Oh, it's just kind of like it doesn't go in the water.
Oh, here we go.
Okay, I'm playing again now.
I like how the how the sun is starting to set and all.
It's really nice.
We need a closer look.
What are you, my dentist?
Wait, did he change my lure?
Yeah, he did.
Um, excuse me, Grandpa.
What are you doing?
Minky's a little gooby.
A gooby.
Dentist.
Open up real wide.
We're gonna look at your teeth.
Oh no, have you been flossing daily?
No, no!
Max, thank you so much for the hot dog.
Thank you.
Okay, ladies, welcome to bamboo ship.
Thank you!
Have you guys listened to Densu2 MVPs today?
Have you done your daily listen?
Remember which guys?
Do these guys...
I don't think they do.
These guys definitely don't.
I think these guys do.
Feast when I was a kid, but the location near me were all
catch and release.
Stopped when I realized I was basically just hurting the
fish for a kernel of corn, which was the bait I used.
Oh!
Yeah, that's kind of tough.
At least, like, let you...
Let you...
Eat them.
Eat what you catch.
Unless maybe you get a zombie salmon.
Someone wants to bite.
No.
Catch and release just sounds so sad.
Let's go back over this way a little bit.
Especially eat the zombie salmon.
Okay.
Zombie salmon to cause the zombie outbreak.
I know, the stars are all...
It's becoming so beautiful.
All these guys, they're the bane of my existence.
Ableclips, welcome back.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Oh, oh, wait, this is good.
I did the upgrades.
I just realized the upgrades might help a lot.
Maybe.
Oh, he's still pulling.
Pink and green and blue and red.
Please see a dentist.
Yeah, you got that.
What is it?
The gum disease.
And you're...
You have...
You have blood coming out when you floss.
No good, no good.
Oh my gosh.
Brown tree.
Wow, we're so tough.
Gingeritis.
Gummy bearitis.
Oh, wait.
What was the gummy bear song?
Wasn't there a gummy bear song?
You're a swim.
No, that's not how it went.
Have you tried actual fishing before?
Yeah.
Tried once and only caught a thumb-sized goldfish.
I don't think I caught anything when I tried before.
I think that would be a really fun Den Setsu trip though
where we go fishing together
Woohoo I don't want that earworm in my head The gummy bear
song I don't remember how I went I'm a gummy bear I'm a
gummy bear I'm a gummy gummy Gummy bear.
I'm a gummy bear.
I get in your hair.
How did it go?
You guys ever gotten gum in your hair?
Oh, wait.
That's the one?
No, it's a different song.
Wait, I don't know how it goes.
We can buy it.
You bring supper or just bragging rights?
We can buy the bigger...
A rod!
Yeah, actually it sucks.
Did you have to shave your head?
I went fishing with my grandparents and my grandma couldn't
stop catching fish after fish.
Turns out she was using fried chicken breading as bait and
the fish were really into that.
Whoa.
Yes, a maple scout, baby.
Dang.
Minky!
That's me!
Alright.
Wait.
Change rod.
Little guppy no more.
Now we're the maple scap.
Alright.
Wait.
Let's keep going.
This game is so pretty.
How's the audio too?
I feel like it might be a little low for you guys.
All right, let's try here.
This is it.
This, wait, this is it.
Oh, wait.
Do they not like my lure, maybe?
Oh, shoot.
I just realized they might not like my lure.
Oh.
Yeah.
Fishing hand can win.
That would be fun.
Just meow on the lake.
I feel like I would need like an instructor though.
I need fishing sensei.
Come on!
Give up.
You are stubborn, but so am I.
Growing up in the south, I sometimes got advice like if you
hear banjos, turn around.
But they never mentioned what if the banjos were this
strong.
Chill.
Were you...
Wait, were you in like Appalachia?
I've heard stories of that too.
Wait, what do you mean if you hear banjos turn around?
What?
Onigiri has experience fishing.
Yeah, I've seen her fish before.
I saw that stream.
Banjos means you're close to somebody's property.
oh i've heard that it's like oh my gosh there's like so many
like people are like because you know like apalachia
mountains are like so old like like it's a very old like
formation of the earth right and so you know that's why you
get people being like there's bigfoot in these woods but
they'll also get people that are like the apalachia woods
just have like a something Something extra in the woods.
Bigfoot playing the banjo.
Exactly.
It could be.
It very well could be.
Bigfoot in your area.
Wait, how does a black pink go?
I did like, I used to do a workout routine.
That was like, it was like a dancing workout.
to Blackpink songs, but you, they did not teach the dance,
like the actual Blackpink dance.
So I was like, well, what, what's the point?
Blackpink is peak workout music, yeah.
It was, it was fun.
I did it for a while, and then I was like, but I want to
like actually learn the dance, you know what I mean?
Actual dance is too hard.
Nah.
Let's move over a little bit.
There were no guys that would pick up my thing.
You guys, like, some of them, some of them are not
interested because they don't care about the size.
Use a smaller rod if your target fish is spooked.
Nah, he's just spooked because he saw...
Oh, it's...
See, see, this guy will eat it.
He's the annoying one though.
Come back down?
Yeah.
Come on.
Yeah, come back my way.
Yes.
Yes, ah!
Also good dating advice.
What, to lure?
what are you like peacocks are we doing like a mating dance
honestly though why didn't humans adopt that so many species
have to like really flaunt their stuff to to impress why why
did humans not think of that some humans do i will tell you
though if you're trying to like impress somebody get really
into a hobby and by that i mean like people think it's like
some people not all but obviously but like some people think
it's like pretty attractive to like when you are really into
something and like you're knowledgeable about it and stuff
like like a musical instrument it means you took the time to
learn it You took the effort.
You put in the effort.
Yeah, people love a passionate people.
Exactly.
I don't remember if these guys bite.
They bite.
I don't think you care.
They bite?
Maybe he bites.
They bite.
bite?
Literally turned around.
What if your hobby is Minto?
Show up on the first date, decked out Minto drip.
Yeah, this is just my passion.
Graphic design and VTubers are my passion.
Focal missing in Appalachia could be because Bigfoot or
folks just getting lost or Bigfoot getting lost and playing
the banjo to cheer himself up.
Oh, he's lonely.
Bigfoot must be lonely if there's only one bigfoot.
And just like, uh...
Um...
Wow, 17!
Nice.
Like, oh, Nessie must be lonely.
If there's one Nessie...
I can't stay long.
Gotta eat.
Just got off work.
Oh, too!
I'm gonna say hi and hope you're all well.
Just saw the post.
I'm gonna reply with some games.
You can ignore.
Thank you, Fallen.
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, let's see.
Let's, uh...
Get...
Oh, 50.
Okay, we'll get the big crankbait.
That will be our next goal.
The cryptids got a hookup with other cryptids.
Do you think like Chupacabra could hook up with Bigfoot and
then create a new species?
We got the Jersey Devil and the Chupacabra together and they
created a new species of cryptid.
Okay.
I
think these guys bite.
Use a smaller rod if you're fit.
Are my fish spooked?
Are you guys spooked?
Are you spooked?
Oh, they seem to be not going towards them.
That'd be some twisted genetics.
It's like when they make the tiger lions.
The ligers.
No, no, no.
The Liger's.
Liger's hero.
I know I think of him every time, too.
It's been so long since I've consumed Zoids media.
And I'm like, why?
Why am I depriving myself?
Why?
Zoids was so great.
Oh my gosh.
I watched a lot.
I watched so much of Zoids as a kid.
As a wee wish myself.
I always think of Zoids as never the actual hiker.
Just means you're cultured.
You.
You right there.
Eat it.
Eat mine.
Oh, you?
You're gonna eat it?
Somebody eat it.
Eat my lure.
There was an RTS called Impossible Creatures.
That lets you just mix and match animals and make a freak
army.
That reminds me...
There was, like, Pokemon things like that, too, right?
Like, sites where you could, like, just kind of pair
different Pokemon together.
And...
Stop it!
Stupid fish.
We're losing him.
Yeah, we lost him.
Dang.
The fusion site.
Yeah!
It was funny.
It was pretty funny.
They still have those Pokemon fusion things.
I've been kind of itching for some more Pokemon recently.
But I don't know which one I would play.
Is he gonna eat it?
Eat it!
Just eat it!
Oh, nice.
Oh, okay.
He's interested.
He's doing a flashy dance.
Pokemon Zah!
Maybe, uh...
I don't know, though.
I'm like, I think I'm just too old school.
Maybe I would like it.
But it's like the concept doesn't seem so interesting to me
at first.
It's so funny because I'm so not, I'm so against like, uh,
what's the word?
Stop it.
So.
Whoa.
Nice.
Um, turn-based.
I usually don't like.
turn-based except for Pokemon.
I think it's kind of freaky that you can get hurt in this
new game, right?
I'm just like, yeah.
Sometimes the Pokemon go after you.
Sometimes you are the victim.
Have you tried Pow World?
A little bit.
I did play a little bit.
Hmm.
You can get hurt in Legends RCS 2.
I think the last one I played...
Oh my gosh, I cannot remember all these games anymore
because, one, I'm old.
And two, they're like, every single game is just like a
letter.
And I'm like, I can't remember what the...
I've played...
I played Q.
I played W Pokemon.
I played...
I played F.
Silent...
Pokemon F.
is it time for a year-long Zoids games arc?
Oh man I've never played a Zoids game Pokemon Rock and Paper
yeah on the DLC scissors
go on ABC Pokemon Learn Your ABCs
playing all the games with letters in alphabetical order
Oh my gosh, where are the fishies that like my...
I like what I got.
You know what, actually I think we could probably sell these
and be able to buy the new...
The new lure, I think so.
Pokemon, go to the polls.
Vote for Minto.
I don't know what for.
Just, just, just put me in.
I just just just write me in put me in coach for president
my long rod is too imposing how can they tell that I have a
long rod that shouldn't matter all right we're buying the
this guy
okay let's go get some biggins I have
long rod energy.
People with long rods need love too.
Don't be afraid, little fish.
I am here to catch you and then sell you.
Wait.
Yes.
Ha ha!
Ooh, a nice throw.
All right, big fish.
Big fish, I'm coming for you.
Oh, that was so fast.
Oh, he's strong.
Okay.
We might got this.
We might have this.
Oh.
No.
Oh no, stop, stop, stop.
Oh no, oh no.
I think we lost it.
Oh, he's gone.
He's gone rogue.
This is catch and release, right?
What am I getting money for then?
Yeah, I know.
They make a break for it and it becomes impossible to like
keep going.
Come on!
No, please.
please stop going crazy
I don't think it's catching release no that's why I was
saying I don't think I would get paid if it were catching
release oh my gosh he's also gone crazy oh please
come on come on grandpa yeah you Zeus frail grandpa arms I
think we might have to upgrade my everything first I think
we might have to upgrade my stuff first before we work our
way up to these big guys gotta tire him out he does seem to
be resisting less it does seem to be and there's our fish
the brown trout large
you guys ever get like the heavy sticker on your luggage and
just the heavy the heavy tag and just makes you feel like
shame i once had it at the exact limit and they still put
one on i was like hey i know i i i pack too light you know
what it is it was always my streaming stuff my laptop uh
like the what's it called the um
the like the cord with the it's not the battery pack but um
that would always make it very heavy and then also
my skin care power supply yes the power supply
It's so ridiculously heavy, all the stuff that I...
That I breathe.
Please keep caring.
Look, I gotta keep my ectoplasm nice and fresh, right?
I like how he's fishing for me.
You know what, I'll let him get these tough fish for me.
Let's see if he can do it with ease.
I'm blocking the entire thing.
Come on, game.
Oh my god, he got him so easily.
Oh, nice, nice.
Okay, we're just gonna let it, let the CPU play for a bit.
This feels like that, what's it called?
That AFK fishing game that...
Okay, the game is actually playing for me.
That's crazy.
It's like stupid VTuber.
Come on, we're catching the small fish now.
It's like the games that you can play.
It's really a Twitch game.
If you've ever seen somebody that is AFK on Twitch,
sometimes they'll have a fish thing.
I think that's part of the reason Twitch kind of drives me
crazy.
is because I feel like and I don't know obviously it's not
going to be for everybody but I feel like with a lot of
YouTube streams the culture here is more like I'm having a
conversation with you guys right like I'm I am reading your
comments I am I am you know we're talking together you know
but on Twitch it's like so much like I'll see like some
streamers streaming and like they have that like fish thing
on and the whole chat is just is just people doing like
exclamation point fish exclamation point fish and the
streamer is kind of like i'm like why are you streaming like
just make youtube videos if you don't care about reading
your chat i don't understand it yeah exclamation point fish
exclamation point fish
And so I think that's just what I can't get behind.
I'm just so like, wait, wait, wait.
I want to go get our upgrades real quick.
Stop, stop, stop.
Exclamation point, Minto.
It is, it is like just something that I'm not used to at
all.
I'm like, oh, okay.
You don't want to chat.
That's fine.
Whoa, 40 for the line length.
Okay.
Joel Joel Joel Joel Who's Joel Maybe yeah Streamer would
feel lonely Maybe I'm too parasocial Maybe I'm like hey Guys
quit fishing and talk to me Um guys I'm right here Um guys
Um guys I'm right here please talk to me That's the fish on
Twitch.
Oh, okay.
This is how little I know.
Clearly.
But the dog...
Oh!
Pat your companion ten times in one session.
Alright, hold on.
Let's switch out for the big guy.
And for uh...
this guy.
Big guy.
Alright.
Well, no.
Big guy.
Also good dating advice.
What's good dating advice?
I think you're making that up.
Big guy, big pants.
SpongeBob, big pants.
SpongeBob, big guy.
What do you care about?
Oh, never mind.
You care about me.
No, don't go rogue.
Rogue.
Come on.
No, no, don't do it.
Yeah, that's right.
You kind of gotta yank them back a little bit.
You gotta show them who's bouse.
No.
I care about Minto.
Yeah, how you do?
No, we're about to lose a...
Ugh!
I'm a very interactive streamer.
Is that not the norm?
is that an ordinary hey you're gonna have to get better
you're missing okay round two stop it oh we lost him again
you are much more than others I think a lot of streamers
kind of resent their chats I wouldn't say that I don't want
to say I don't want to put that kind of, you know...
You said that, not me.
Can you rate my current skincare routine?
Currently do Cetaphil Cleanser.
Good, good.
Thayer's Toner.
Anua Serum.
Kauzer X.
All-in-One Snail Cream.
Beauty of Josan Moisturizer.
Wow.
I don't know the toner brand, actually, but...
You are exceptional, not the norm.
What?
I think, though, that's also partial.
why I get so distracted in games though because I'm I'm
reading you guys too much it's your fault I'm bad at games
it's a your fault your skincare routine sounds great trophy
weight catch let's go whoa that's a big in holy cow holy cow
we are okay with it yeah you're okay with me but I'm bad?
How bad can I be?
VTuber, how did you?
She was... Wait, wait, hold on.
Let me be... Be... Hold on.
We're making a song right now.
How bad can I be?
I would have hit him if it were me.
How bad can I possibly be?
The VTuber's playing.
But she's not even slaying.
She's just yapping while the fish are...
What is this guy doing?
I just got back.
What's happening?
Uh, autobiography?
The fishler.
Yeah, napping.
That's a good one.
She might as well be napping.
And the games are losing.
She's not even cruising.
They all started grooving.
Twitch viewers are Tendere with their Oshi.
They bully them but love them.
I don't know.
I feel like I get bullied too sometimes.
I think I get bullied too.
I scrub my face with a washcloth in the shower in the
morning and wipe it with a wet paper towel before bed.
The reals learn.
Yeah.
Wet paper towel.
For some reason I didn't imagine a wet paper towel.
I imagine like, you know how sometimes people describe like
a pathetic animal being like it looks like a wet towel.
Like a wet animal, like a wet cat or something.
That's what I am.
I'm just picking up the whole wet cat and like motorboating
it.
Like, bb.
You know what?
Okay.
Everybody who is a pet owner can agree with me on this.
One of the worst things with an animal, with your pet, with
your pet, is going to pet your pet.
And they're wet.
that rhyme but you know what i mean you go to pet your pet
and you're like why are you mysteriously wet and what is the
substance it's so scary it's actually it's actually
terrifying because you're just like what is this what is it
is this guy gonna eat come on come on i'm so attractive i'm
doing a little twisty dance You were in.
You're in.
Oh, yeah.
Then he got to do a smell check.
I don't want to put my nose near.
What was it in your case?
The last time this happened to me, my cat...
So sometimes he...
Sometimes he puts his cheek too far into the running water
dish that he has.
And then, like, when he lays, he lays his head down on
himself.
And so, he will,
yeah.
So, sometimes it's usually that.
Or, there's been times, like, depending on what kind of, I
had a different water dish for him.
And he would just, like, stick his, you know, some cats do
that.
They just stick their heads inside of it.
And he would do that.
Oh, oh, no.
Try a different lure.
If the fish aren't interested.
why is nobody interested in me I'm doing an attractive dance
please hope you had a great day enjoy this game thank you
Quinn thank you the log book will tell you I don't even know
what I'm looking at though am I looking at oh we don't know
the guy in the wall walleye wally wally we the wally a
relatively calm minto stream to put up on the tv let's go
yeah we're just fishing we like fishing irl also 12 months
thank you i can't say that i like fishing irl because i've
haven't had so many opportunities but oh my gosh we've been
fishing literally all night i'm like i bet Rusty's at the
shop like looking out the window being like that guy's not
right that guy's not right the Wally you know I've never
seen that movie before Wally
I've never seen it
go watch it should I watch it tonight Wally.
Wally.
Oh, here we go.
$57.
Let's go.
That was the only guy I got, though.
I ain't a nice when the good ones come back.
Welcome, pal.
Oh, see, he likes me.
Actually, he's just saying that because he's just like,
there's something all wrong with that guy.
Here for worms are winning, because I'll tell you, this
year's Monster Wally trophy.
get a monster wally ain't nobody broke the record yet 19
pounds last year it was little ev jane that took the crown
surprised everyone too minto just saying my name over and
over but you're a romance of a romantic city
wally watch along please minky yeah Tiny gal with a busted
boat motor and a cooler full of snacks.
Hulled a beast like it was nothing.
Rules are simple.
Any rod, any lure, no treats.
You land a Wally heavier than Evie Jeans, and that trophy is
yours.
Along with a year's worth of bragging rights.
I want one bragging rights.
I want monetary compensation.
Surprise Wally you watch along after this stream.
Yeah?
Little tip for you.
no point trying to wrangle a beast like that with poor gear
okay we need this this is for the wally the heavy spoon bait
but i wish i could also upgrade my strength we'll go back
we'll we'll fish for and say we only pay an exposure i don't
want bragging rights i want pictures of spider-man I think
it's pronounced walleye.
Yeah, but...
I like saying walley is fun.
Walley.
Alright.
Fish in here.
This is it.
Come to me, or walley.
Willed it into existence?
Come on, come on.
Come on.
Come on!
This guy's feisty.
I'll give him that.
Yes.
I was scared for a second.
I thought we lost it for a second.
I wish I could reel faster, you know.
He's tired now though, he's tired.
Or maybe not.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, he's tired, he's tired, he's tired.
Come on!
Yeah?
Yeah!
Brown trout!
Suspenseful.
It truly is.
So the Wally...
It's only when we haven't caught.
Extra large.
Spoon bait.
Wait, oh, I didn't change it, did I?
Now I think about it.
There we go, the heavy spoon bait.
I'm here for some whims to catch Wally.
But they're a little more green.
Right here.
Is it these guys here?
Oh, someone's interested.
Am I attracting you?
Yeah.
No.
Walleye is one of my favorite southeast Michiganders have
specialized techniques to catch them What could that be What
do these guys look like again?
Okay, they have like the white underneath Like a lighter
underneath Oh, there's one, there's one, there's one He's
shining, he's shining Hold on Let's do this side Okay Here
we go, here we go.
I can't tell what these ones are though.
Uh...
Spass, maybe?
This guy is huge.
Oh, sorry, my head is...
This guy!
The guy just picked up!
Oh, dang it!
Oh my god!
He was too huge!
I didn't say the change!
That's our 20-pounder.
No!
Get away from me!
Oh,
here we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes.
There we go, here we go.
Yeah, he's a real unit.
He's scary.
We are... I know we are not ready for him.
That's like going to the Elite Four when we've just beat
Misty.
We're not ready.
oh oh oh no go she's above your pay grid hey i will take
i've i've done jobs that i felt i was getting i feel like i
get paid too much for this job
i've done jobs though where i'm like i am not qualified for
this oh no no no no no no i'll take the money
oh my gosh
Okay.
Get him when he's up.
Get him when he's out.
Yeah, when he can't breathe.
Woo!
We got the Wally!
Hey, this is an eight pounder.
Eight pounder Wally.
Fake it till you make it is my policy.
It's a good policy, honestly.
Okay.
Don't turn around.
I'm not interested in you.
I'm interested in this.
this bad boy.
Oh, yeah.
An eight-pound fish is... I know, he does weigh more than
me.
I weigh zero pounds!
That's crazy.
Actually, all of these fish weigh more than me.
It's funny.
I think people thought I was taller than what I really am.
Because I posted my reference sheet recently.
And I got several comments from people being like, I thought
you were...
so tall and I was like where did this information who
thought this come on oh my gosh we almost had him oh come on
come on oh my gosh we're so close come on come on yes
yeah everyone is always talking about you being tiny I don't
know but some people I guess like maybe if you don't I mean
not everyone's gonna catch every part of a or anything like
that so if you don't hear that i don't know maybe i give off
really big tall energy now we have the vision of you getting
pulled through the air while trying to fish
i give big big energy before this though um we're just gonna
catch a small fish so that we can
yeah we'll do this one
I regret to inform you, you do not have big, tall energy.
Don't say, no, that's not true at all.
Because then why else would people think that I'm massive?
I'm huge in Japan.
How did this guy live?
I had literally had him.
I miss those shirts.
It's the hot.
Truly, it must be.
Huge money!
Let's go!
Wait, what is this?
Now that's what I call a comeback.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Wait, what are you trying to get me to buy?
There's something on an exclamation point.
Is it this?
Minto is not tall, but her heart is huge.
I'm the Grinch.
The timber jack rod.
Oh, oh, it just wants me to click on it.
Oh, okay, because I can't buy it.
I couldn't buy it before.
Okay.
Oh, I think I'm going to be able to buy that big boy now.
Not buy him.
Sorry.
I could pay him off, maybe.
Oh, you want me to tip?
You're a real gem.
You know that?
I think he likes me.
But I'll be.
A fish from every hole in the fork.
Not too shabby, bud.
Looks like your rod's still twitching.
And wouldn't you know it?
There's a sweet little spot-up river at Beaver.
damn hang on I'll scribble it on your map don't say I never
gave up gave you nothing oh we're going somewhere new oh
nice let's go whoa new
place I'm
gonna become a fisherman if we can get paid in 80 cents it's
it's so easy guys it's so easy.
Banjo and the moonlight.
It's too beautiful.
Oh, new species.
Oh, yeah.
I guess the shiny ones?
Okay, I'm understanding now.
The shiny ones are ones that I have not caught yet because
only the Wally was shiny before.
I know you want me.
You wanted me.
Why don't you want me anymore?
Oh, you do.
Oh, no, you're teaching.
me.
No,
they are interested.
Shut up, game.
They are interested.
See?
Ooh, watch me dance.
You can dance.
You can drive.
Having the time of your afterlife.
Ooh.
This is sad.
Crank bait.
Yeah.
Fishing queen.
Young and sweet lures.
17 inches.
Actually not very big is it.
Oh wait.
Like you know what?
Why am I going through this effort?
Okay.
Crank bait.
Jig head.
Do I have that?
Wait, what did I do?
Sorry, not the lure, the lion.
I don't have!
I don't have it!
I only have a crankbait.
Wait, someone else like something else, though.
What did you like?
Oh, you like the crankbait.
Oh, because you're the brown trout.
Just, you're brown trout, just upstream.
Is that a small dog in an anime?
movie that picks fights with all the bigger dogs.
What?
Ooh!
Wait, snooze.
I can go to sleep?
Oh my gosh.
I could actually...
I can actually rest.
Wait, sorry.
Was it crankbait?
Yes.
Just making sure.
I'm not picking fights.
Crankbait.
Yeah.
New species- oh these guys are teeny tiny.
Little babies.
There's no...
Okay, what do you guys like?
Oh, what do you went to?
A drop shot!
How do you think they got the name The Long Nose Sucker?
Wait.
We got one!
The long nose sucker!
Come here, you little sucker.
We got him!
Bottom feeders with the... They don't look...
At least the image of them does not look very long.
They look quite average, actually.
Wait, these ones are kind of bigger, though.
We'll focus on these guys.
They do look like bottom feeders, though.
They're all hanging out downstairs.
you ever think about how like lobster and stuff used to be
like really people thought it was really disgusting and then
the marketing for it changed and then it was just like oh
lobster it's a delicacy oh i thought minta was the cute
ghost of it on my tv that's me that's me
I said that in a chat this week.
Oh, really?
That's crazy.
Oysters, too?
I can't get behind oysters.
Actually, this is the worst part.
I say I don't like oysters, but I've never tried one.
I just know I won't like the texture.
I just know I won't like it.
Okay, these guys ain't buying.
You don't blame me?
Yeah.
You don't chew, you just swallow it.
I know that scares me.
I'm a literal dog.
You give me something and I keep it in my mouth and you're
like, spit, spit.
And I'm like, instead you'd be like, you'd be like, you have
to swallow it.
And I'd be like, you know,
you'd be like, you have to, it's in one go, but I'd be like,
no.
Drop it, drop it.
We could solve a giant ecological issue that affects the
whole U.S.
if we ate carp.
But people who never ate carp in their life goes, Poor
person, fish.
Well, what if it just tastes bad?
I think they just gotta rename it.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes renaming something.
Like, carp sounds stupid.
Sorry.
Sorry to carp.
It tastes pretty good?
Yeah.
What are we spitting and or swallowing?
Oyster?
It's kind of bony.
Yeah.
Let's go for the big...
Let's try.
I could eat like 500 raw oysters at any given moment.
That's crazy.
I've also heard of like...
There's like some sort of...
Some sort of sickness you can get from the oyster, so...
I'm having a hard time out here, folks.
I think we gotta go back to our previous location.
And...
Oh, what?
Whoa.
Don't do that to me.
I saw you were interested.
Just chatting?
Nah, just casting.
Is he a long nose sucker?
Because he's a sucker with a long nose?
Or because he's suckers on long noses?
That's what I thought, too.
I was like, maybe he's like...
On people's noses.
Maybe.
Maybe what had happened was...
He, like, someone caught it, and it, like, went, like, a
cartoon moment.
It got flipped in the air, and then he got stuck on the
guy's nose and started to just, and that's how he got the
name.
That's honestly what I was thinking.
Yeah, I think we need to save for new lures.
Yeah, I was, yeah.
True and factual.
I was there, I was there.
I was there.
I saw it all happen.
That guy?
Me.
Remember I told you about that one time I went fishing?
Crazy.
Crazy stuff happened.
There was a hold.
I was on the news and everything.
I mean, it was my local news, but...
You guys asked for a story.
Wait, did I change my thing?
No.
Hold on.
Everybody clapped.
It's awesome.
It's true.
I was the fish.
Oh my gosh.
It's been so long.
No, no, no, no.
No.
He is too scary.
Don't look at my...
Don't look at my lure again.
Oh!
Oh, he's flying!
Come on.
No, no.
Oh no, he's going rogue.
Come on.
Final boss of the lake, guys.
Seriously.
Everybody is literally cowering over this guy.
I mean, I don't know how territorial fish can be, I'm sure.
probably some of these things depend on the type of fish but
but can you imagine everybody's eating chowing down and then
this guy comes up and they're like big way the big Wally big
Wally's here he's like I'm big Wally fish can get crazy
territorial group are I mean oh you know I have heard that
about like a beta fish right like Like you shouldn't have
more than one beta fish in a tank.
I was definitely...
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Not for you.
Don't be greedy.
No, no, no.
I like that it immediately just disconnects.
I fell victim to getting a beta fish.
And loving my beta fish so much that I was like...
I...
beta fish to be so happy and so full and I fell victim to
pouring the whole bag of food that I received into his into
his quaint tank he lived he lived for a while even she
exploded him no no I didn't
He was just...
Can fish get fat?
Like, do fish...
Like...
You kind of like, you know how you shouldn't feed birds.
Uh...
Like rice and stuff.
Right?
Like, that will make their tummies explode.
Is there... Stop!
Is there something similar to...
To fish?
Fish can keep growing.
Oh, I have heard that!
Like, a gold fish that's been released to the wild and they
they they usually they grow to the size of their tank but oh
man release a goldfish and they'll grow to the size of the
pond
fat fish make the tastiest fish
stop why would you even grab it if you're just gonna be like
that not a team player wait are you interested No?
Oh!
We've lost before we could even start.
Stop!
Go away.
My five-year-old nephew may have recently made that food
mistake with his brother's beta.
Sadly, the fish was never the same after.
Oh, geez.
Magic carp was a cautionary tale.
This guy is rogue.
It's insane.
I am clearing out the population of wallies in this river,
though.
Oh, the tension, the tension.
Not just the tension, the suspense, but also the tension of
my line.
No, no, no, don't do it.
Don't do it.
Oh my god, he's so strong.
Ugh.
Fine, we'll go with the stinking brown trout.
We'll go with the brown trout.
I think I need to move more over, actually.
I like that you can play it either, like, play, play this
game, or you can just idle it and, like, let it go forever.
room.
Imagine how much, like, cash money I can make.
I, like, go for a walk for an hour and come back.
Aren't you a brown trout?
Yes.
Passive income.
Yeah.
If I got real serious about this game, which I fear I might,
just let grandpa do the fishing he's a pro i feel like i'm
actually like like the grand kid in the boat that he's
allowing to do the fishing and then if i let him take over
he's just like let me show you how a real fisherman does it
you know i'm the dog
Big dog.
Wait, little dog.
Ow!
Big dog.
Woof, woof.
Chad paw.
No.
There's like a DLC or something for this game that you can
get a cat.
Honestly, I should have bought it.
Where'd my fish go?
Oh, there he is.
Even with the upgrades, though, These guys are tricky.
Do you think you give off big dog or little dog energy?
I think I am the big dog.
I am the big dog.
Kind of miss that game.
Lifeline.
Me too.
I kind of do too.
There's like certain series that I'll like just keep
quoting, you know?
That's how you know that it is so memorable to me.
You know, if I can't stop quoting a game, it was just that,
like, that much of an experience for me.
Lifeline.
Nice!
Lifeline was just such a...
Yeah.
Some lines really do stick in your head forever.
Yeah, they really do.
Oh, wait.
I don't think there's any more.
What are these tiny guys?
Are they not small brown trout?
Wait, they're shiny.
Wait, so are these guys.
Curious.
Up there with your outer wild streams.
Think about outer wilds is there's nothing too close.
From the...
Game itself, right?
I mean, there's just so little dialogue in it.
Yeah, like Roadrunner cartoons.
Roadrunner cartoons.
Just the banjo.
Okay, the music from Outer Wows, yeah.
I just sometimes will just kind of like be sitting there and
I'll be like,
I do think the...
It's so emoy.
So emoy!
Oh my gosh!
Crazy!
This guy!
It is a brown trout!
Good dude.
Good boy.
Okay.
Yeah, I know it's a return.
Uh-oh.
No.
Cops of marshmallow on a stick.
I always quote, I tried everything I could think of and
neither one worked.
What is that from?
Is that from a...
The love letters on brittle hollow are pretty quotable if
depressing.
Yeah, you could quote like the Carthians and stuff.
It's a gabrolone.
54!
Whoa!
Wait, so...
Well, I'll be back in the land of leeches and lunkers, are
you?
Don't just stand there like a stone perch, grab a coffee and
tell me what trouble you've been into.
Oh, here we go.
The jig head, the jig is up head, and the drop shot.
I feel though...
I feel...
Wait.
Can I...
Can I put this on any rod?
Can I put this on my Maple Scout?
Who are you calling Jade?
Definitely rod upgrades.
Alright, like I really feel like I need them.
Oh, we can max out the strength!
Huge.
Okay, let's go get some more money.
supposed to work on any rod okay we'll get some more wallies
and then we will make a big big buku bucks and then we'll
buy the the lures
i still don't think i can get the big guy but we'll see he
might be too big
this or dredge oh no no i love dredge i love dredge i was
literally thinking of dredge the other day and i think
that's what influenced me to get this to get this and play
it i was like man i just dredge you know what also like
scratched and itch that dredge kind of scratched was uh Dave
the Diver.
That game was also so fun, too.
Oh, man.
I love dredge, though.
I love dredge.
Did you finish, Dave?
I did, I did, actually.
Hey, big boy.
Oh, wow.
We lost it immediately.
That was pretty pathetic.
Just I started Dredge today.
I think you'll like it.
I hope you like it.
You'll need an XL rod for the big guy.
Well, let him.
We'll just ignore him for now.
Hey you.
No!
You made me miss the other guy.
Dredge had the right amount of unsettling and comfy.
Yeah.
I just, I wish I could, I wish there was like an endless
mode.
Which I guess you could just keep going.
You could just never do the story at all.
Made him near the surface.
Oh, wait, that's so smart.
Come on.
Hey, stop going crazy.
What is this?
Dredge roguelike.
It's just so fun.
Fishing games are just, I don't know.
They're like calming and like they're exactly like just so
nice.
Maybe I do always wish I was wishing I was
Oh, whoops.
Oh, what are you barking at?
What are you barking at, boy?
They're peaceful and simple.
I saw that, what's it called?
That new
game is going to be the one that i did the demo for that
should be coming out soon-ish so we could check that out
yeah the fish head one yeah yeah yeah the fishing one
fishing is in right now fishing games are in fishing games
really get you hooked
Do I need to rebrand?
Do I need to become a fisher instead of a maid?
A ghost fisher?
Juanito.
It wasn't me.
It was a super chat.
Thank you so much for the super chat, by the way.
Fisher maid.
Yeah, but I can't be a ghost fisher maid.
Something's gotta go and I can't really get rid of the ghost
part.
Please!
One thing about these guys, though, is the pain in the butt.
Whoa, my biggest Wally!
Let's go.
I think there was one more.
Like the flying Dutchman.
Oh my gosh.
What if?
Come on.
Oh my god, he just...
He's too fast.
That's scary.
Oh my gosh!
Guys, I did it!
Legendary catch!
Land a big enough Wally to get on the wall in Rusty's tackle
shop.
He literally just, like, jumped into my boat.
He wanted me.
He wanted to be here.
That was crazy.
Legendary fish.
You know what?
Let's just go.
Let's go turn in our...
I got it all on camera!
Send it to the news!
Awesome.
Rusty will never believe this.
Ten sets no fish.
The lake's boss.
Tell the internet!
Post it on TikTok!
Please draw Minto next to our legendary guest.
you yeah 161 yeah uh hello oh there it is well i'll be you
went and did it that fish on the wall over 20 pounds of pure
muscle a real beauty folks been stopping by just to see it
point already even even jean swore she's coming back swing
swing swing swimming swinging You've earned your bragging
rights.
Names on the board.
Trophy's yours.
And there's a new legend over the counter.
Just don't let it get to your head.
Wally, have a way of humbling folks.
Yeah, she's annoying.
That guy was annoying.
Oh, whoops.
She just says the same thing.
Nice!
Oh my gosh, we're so close to even to getting the timber
jack.
But...
Wait, can I not buy these here?
Oh, I guess I can.
Oh, it shows me...
Oh, it shows what I don't have.
Yeah, I'm stupid.
We'll get that.
Fishermaid is trending.
News travels fast.
Let's just get all the baits.
Or, I mean, the lure, sorry.
And then...
We can max this.
Oh, my gosh.
We're killing it.
And that's maxed!
Next?
I gotta get 200 coin for a boat.
Oh, I forgot about my storage too, my inventory.
I just focused on the upgrades for now.
Wait a second, wait a second, wait a second.
I think we can go to the next area.
Uh, Yeah, we're gonna keep on fishing.
Go to Beaver Dam.
Alright,
now...
Let's stop right here.
And let's get our drop shot on for the long-nose sucker.
Or the jig head.
We'll try the jig head.
I guess the Maple Scout is what we need.
Alright.
We're gonna keep on fishing.
fishing and take, aren't you?
Does she know it's walleye?
Or is she just being silly?
I'm always serious.
I'm always very serious, actually.
He's tiny, but he packs a punch.
Large mouthpass!
Yippee!
Wait, what about this guy over here?
I've never told a joke ever once.
I've never told a single joke.
I don't even know how to smile.
I can't believe that guy literally jumped into my boat.
I think fish do want me.
Fish want me.
Women want me.
Yeah, big ol' bears.
Let's go.
They call her straight-faced Minto.
She's never...
She was born...
When she was born, aka died, she never laughed.
There's a lot of these guys here, so...
Oh, Minto!
Oh, ha!
Oh, ho!
Yes.
Come on, come on.
Come on.
Kuy, kuy, kuy.
They've never told a joke?
Why so serial?
No, no, no!
No, he's gone rogue!
You bastard.
Mood.
There was rain on the day she was born.
This guy's been tailing me.
So interested.
All right, let's go show.
Dang fish.
I know.
Dang!
You really start getting money, like, really fast once,
uh...
Well, I'll be.
A haul like that?
You're on fire.
That's what I'm saying.
I did have an...
Oh, this exclamation point.
Thanks, I hate.
Ain't nothing like hauling.
in a fat old large mouth bass after giving you a workout.
Heard there's a swarm of little rock bass up at the
mistwood.
Thicker than skeezers on a July evening.
Ta-per-ta-ku!
I think they'll never jokes, but I know this cool guy named
Hugh Morris.
That's got a lot of jokes in Riz.
I watched the Japanese direct for...
for...
What's it called?
For Tomodachi Life after this morning.
And they did not...
Okay.
They didn't have a clown.
Like Hugh Morris.
The Miis were different.
Yeah, the Miis were different and they didn't have a clown.
The EU version had a clown.
But you know how after the girl gets rejected by Patrick?
in the Tomodachi Life American one and she also gets
rejected by a guy in the EU one.
She goes to Hugh Morris, right?
But in the Japanese version, because there's no clown guy,
she instead goes with her old man professor.
I was like, wait a second.
I was like, wait, wait, wait.
Like, she's just like...
She calls him, like, something, Sensei.
And I was like, um...
So instead, the Western versions put in a clown!
It's so funny.
Did he reject her, too?
Yeah, yeah.
He went with, like, the other...
a professor or other teacher or whoever who uh who that she
was also wearing like the sheet the shirt that said like i
love i don't know what his name is i'll just it's just so
it's so funny i was like she was yeah oh what do we have now
golden fork river wow wait but i haven't even gotten the
fish here yet wait wait wait why does that seem so
quintessentially JP it's so it really is at least he was a
responsible adult I guess look I'm not I'm not judging her
for you know being attracted to an older gentleman you know
but it's just very funny that is that a It's just very funny
that that was the Japanese version while the the western
versions were all like Oh yeah, clowns
So funny Okay, let's see what we got here Because I think I
discovered a new guy Brown trout Beaver dam the beaver Oh,
oh, crap pie Oh,
that looks like a cat Catfish.
Guys, the crap pie!
Okay, spoon bait.
Maybe there's one here.
I have a heavy spoon bait.
That should work.
Fish names are so fun.
Oh, wait.
Is it this tiny guy right here?
No,
that's...
Okay.
I think we gotta go to the smaller one.
Crap pie.
Oh, was it crappy?
What is it?
Is it a crappy?
Yeah, guys, I was just kidding.
I know it was a crappy this whole time.
That's so silly.
Whoa, this guy has, like, glowing eyes.
What's up with him?
Oh.
It's not a Wally.
What the heck?
Every time I try to get the big guys, I switch to the other
side.
Serious professional VTuber.
I'm a VTuber.
I never said I was a V-reader.
Oh, oops.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
Yeah, drop shop.
Wait, stop, stop, stop!
Most people pronounce it croppy.
It, like, crops in a field.
Well, that's just denying his proper name.
I think I know what they went for.
I know what the intentions were.
Someone had a bad time with that guy.
Crappy and proud.
Ooh!
Trophy weight catch!
Let's go!
Let's go.
I've never heard crappy.
Uh oh.
The fishers are fighting.
These guys are easy to catch too.
I hope they're worth lots of money.
We got catfish.
Have you guys ever been catfish before?
Like, I think I have not talked to enough people to, like,
online to feel like I...
To be catfish.
Like, actually, like, a lot of people that I met were, like,
at anime conventions and stuff, so...
No, no.
I guess, like, I don't know.
Like, you hear about the people that get catfish, and
they're like, Oh, I've known this person for five years.
and we've never talked, we've only talked on the phone and
like a voice call or something, we've never video called.
Things like that.
But I'm just like, at that point, if I were, you know, if I
were just friends with the person, maybe it'd be one thing.
But if it's like a romantic attraction, I think it would be
wise to video call.
My Nigerian prince friend is real.
I believe, I believe.
Yeah, I know that guy's real.
Back with a bounty, eh?
Your rod's earning its cape.
Ah, yeah.
All right, let's, uh...
What are the licenses?
I'm afraid to press it, because I don't know what it will
do.
Oh, we can get the leaky bucket!
Oh, motor speed.
Wait, so if I...
Probably unlocks places.
I guess so.
One time someone texted me pretending they were a girl I had
a crush on is a prank!
I don't know if that counts.
What the heck?
I occasionally get texts from a person that like caught...
They're just like...
They are constantly telling whoever they're trying to text
to wake up.
They're like, wake up!
Wake up!
I'm here!
Get out of bed!
Like, how do they know?
If their texts are going to me.
Is this person just asleep all the time?
I wasn't one of the girls he was dating by pretending to be
a lesbian, so it wasn't as bad for me.
Wait.
Oh.
So you were just friends?
All right, five, wait, six fish in our leaky bucket.
That's right, that's right.
I think we should start aiming for the timber jack too,
maybe.
Let's get all the, did I get all the fish in here actually?
No, I think about it.
Wait, change boat.
Yeah!
Have you ever dreamed that you were streaming?
When I first started streaming, like all the time.
I would have nightmares that I was still streaming.
And I would nightmares that I was like streaming.
And that...
I would have nightmares that I would be streaming.
And I would fart in my sleep.
And then you guys would...
That wasn't a dream.
What, no!
That wasn't a nightmare, me.
Did you wake up screaming when you were dreaming of
streaming?
Oh, he got sick of me.
He got sick of waiting.
I once got random calls and voicemails from four different
people looking for an Evan to deliver his grandma's meds.
Why is that so sad?
That's like important stuff.
It was a premonition.
That's why I don't sleep on stream.
Oh.
It's just so funny.
Yeah.
I've told this story before.
but one time I had a dream that I was posting a link to
something that I was like watching in chat but I
accidentally copied the link of a Jake Paul video and then I
posted that in chat and everybody made fun of me and they
were like man watch his Jake Paul man watch his Jake Paul
and I was like no I don't know I never like I've never
watched Jake Paul before and
That was forever ago.
Yeah, that was a long time ago.
Yeah, I don't have dreams about streaming anymore, though.
The other night I had a dream about being a spy.
I was like a spy kid.
And I remember there was like, I had like a agent partner,
right?
Like another spy.
And he was a guy in my room.
I was trying to hide him from my mom.
Because I was just like, this is important.
My mom doesn't know I'm a spy.
And we're like investigating.
something in this important spy business and I was like it
was like he would like he would like sit in my room I
remember I would try to disguise him like as like a teddy
bear and he would sit in my room like crisscross applesauce
but he was like massive he was like the biggest adult ever
my mom would come into my room be like where'd that teddy
bear come from don't worry about it mom i'm just a kid i'm
just a kid of course i would have a teddy bear in my room
the et strategy how are you sure about that your mom isn't a
spy she's spying on me oh my gosh drama how does that stack
up to the time you dreamt about pooping oh my gosh yes i
once dreamt that i
I don't sleep with my earbuds in anymore because one time
one fell out and it like somehow is I guess I rolled around
a lot and it and it kind of like got underneath my back and
I had a dream that I pooped out a rock and I was so I was so
sad about it I was crying I was crying about it and
I was like because I mean I would think I think anybody
would cry if they pooped out a rock because that's really
concerning how did that how did that get in there I'm crying
I'm crying thinking about it again
is that a rock fact why is it this guy catching anything
What I'm doing is auto time.
What?
There's no one's biting.
Oh my gosh.
No one's biting.
Yeah, the princess in the pee moment.
Actually, actually.
Princess in the pee 2020's edition sounds weird.
Just thinking about pooping out rocks.
Oh, I forgot we got six things now.
Alright.
Let's see.
Um, I think we've caught everything in this.
Oh, no.
The crappy.
The crap pie.
Good morning, Vito.
It's my birthday today.
Can I get a birthday?
Tofu!
Happy birthday.
Happy, happy birthday.
All of this after saying you are not a funny Vito.
I don't know if my dreams are very funny.
Spoon bite.
I think a small spoon.
Oh, for the crappy.
Best for a crap pie.
Alright.
I'm cooking up some crap pie.
Do you remember getting to stream?
How did you get here?
And what were you doing before?
Inception made me question everything after watching the
movie.
I think I remember.
What did I do today?
Today was pretty laid back for me, actually.
Yesterday I did, like, so much work that I was like, today,
we're taking it easy.
What are these guys?
Are these tiny crappies?
Did you get to nap?
I did!
I took, like, a, I took, like, a little bit of a nap.
Okay, that's... This is clearly not our...
Not our dino.
So, I've been watching this guy he's been like trying to oh
he's been trying to ride the dinosaur ride at animal kingdom
as many times as possible and before the ride shuts down
he's at like 200 right now it's kind of crazy but he's been
going at it for like two weeks and now he'll be before he
was just like He was like 13 days until dinosaur closes and
now you guys now he's saying hours now he's what is this one
he's saying hours now he's like a hundred hours until
dinosaur closes oh it's so painful
It's so sad.
Maybe it's a large mouth bass.
But he's huge.
Or a brown...
I wonder if this is the boss of this river.
Do we need to do another dinosaur karaoke?
No, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I am pretty sad though that I didn't get to go on it one
more time.
Oh, he doesn't seem interested at all.
Hello?
It's the large mouth bass, so I'm right, right?
Jighead.
I think that's what I put on.
But I have somebody that was going to the parks and they
asked, you know what's really messed up?
They...
Oh.
Are you interested?
I'll take you.
They are putting out merch.
Can you believe this?
They are putting out merch for the closure of this ride.
I'm angry about it.
I think this guy can't see.
I think he's blind, and I don't mean...
I mean that, like, literally.
Graduation merch!
It is!
It's graduation merch!
For real!
Yeah, but somebody is going to the parks.
for me and they said that they would try and get me a hat if
there were any left oops
when you put it like that it sounds messed up it's funny
because like idols i i guess i guess it depends on the
vtuber i know hololive they do graduation merch right don't
they sometimes depends but uh okay I don't think I can get
that guy or just yeah but um depends yeah sometimes I do but
uh yeah idols like like like you know regular idols not
VTuber idols or anything they put out graduation merch like
all the time it's like nothing even remotely like strange
but i don't know it feels to me like you know it feels
completely different because when an idol graduates like
it's her decision that she wants to do something else you
know like here they decided that it was the end of dinosaur
you know what i mean like they chose to close the ride like
this is not dinosaur's decision So it makes me angry.
I feel like it's less weird when an artist is doing it as a
farewell than when a corporal is cynically doing it for
profits.
Exactly, exactly.
I have some of the Pikami graduation merch.
Me too.
I was just looking at my Pikami.
I was going, I was searching for some stuff.
Oh my gosh, yeah.
I was, I, um, yeah, I found my Pikachu.
Pikachu.
Oh my gosh.
My Pikami.
uh face mask like the eye eye mask um black text white
background thank you for your continued support of dinosaur
the ride but i found that my pygmy eye mask because uh good
luck to dinosaur the ride and their future endeavors i want
them to send or not send i want them to sell some of the
stuff like the i wonder if if it's possible to buy some of
the ass not that Do you call them assets?
What do you call them?
The decorations of Dinosaur the Ride?
Like the things that say the Dinosaur Institute?
I want that.
But the reason I found my peek-a-me-eye mask earlier is
because...
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I'm such a stinking sucker for...
For technology gimmicks.
Okay.
Like...
And I mean that.
So I saw a video the other day that was just like...
fall of the one plus phone things like that i had a one plus
phone i had a one plus phone and in the video they mentioned
the next the next bit the next bit phone i had that phone i
had that and then they also mentioned the essential phone i
had that phone i had that and i was like i don't i i guess i
don't consider myself like a
am a sucker for a gimmick and so recently i was kind of
looking at the new s26 that like the features of that it's
kind of awesome though like you are the subject of the video
pretty much um did you have a windows phone at some point
shut up shut up anyway um if you have you guys seen the
features ultra because it's kind of all it's not i mean it's
not even just the ultra it's kind of awesome though because
it has like a privacy screen feature on it like built into
the phone and then also you can dim how much you want the
privacy screen to be like shown and then also with yeah you
can have selective privacy so you can be like i don't mind
if my whole screen is shown but for like text alerts and
text like you know notifications that pop up i want those
Only to be privacy screen.
It's kind of insane.
I was like, whoa, wait.
This is like kind of nice.
And so I was thinking, you know, my phone, I don't need one.
But I've been kind of like, I get itching for a new phone.
And that's why I've had, that's why I've had the next bit.
And that's why I've had the essential phone.
And that's why I've had a OnePlus phone.
i've had all these phones because i'm like i'm just i like
little gadgets you know i love buying new gadgets i even had
for my essential phone if you don't know what that was the
essential phone i i charged it earlier it still works um but
what what is this the time oh is this the idle time was that
okay uh flagship tech is fun i know and usually they try new
things like i was looking at the nothing phone earlier too
if i had a better camera i would probably get it but um uh
the essential phone was pretty cool because it had like
little it had two little notches in the back of the phone
and they were like advertising attachments for it and so
what i had was like a 360 cam attachment that like was
magnetic it almost like a like the mag like the mag safe you
know like magnetic ring and it yeah like it just attaches to
it and then i i have filled i filled things with my 360
camera it was pretty cool yeah so modular phones i know it's
just like you know I think, honestly, I would love...
Biggest catch!
Nice.
I would love Samsung more if it didn't have all, like, the
bloatware and everything.
But...
Um...
Yeah, and so I was thinking recently, I was like, oh my
gosh, I'm just...
I've been struggling not to get one of the flip phones.
I was...
I was like, I want, like, the Z flip so bad.
But I don't need it!
So I'm been like but I want a little gadget they're so
expensive I know I know they break a lot do they I know that
like that I I don't need it for one and two like there's
more probably downsides than been good sides.
There was another phone I was looking at.
Um, oh my gosh.
What was it called?
Because have you guys noticed that like square phones are
kind of they're kind of like becoming more popular?
Oh, what was it called?
I can't remember.
I keep watching vids on 3D printing gear and I always feel
like I need this stuff and then almost never use it, yeah.
Square, yeah.
There's more flagships, more brands coming out with like,
not rectangular phones.
Kind of like how the flip phone is when it's flipped, or not
flipped out, but like closed.
Yeah.
So, when are you starting a tech channel, I'm not a tech
person But I watched lots of tech videos In fact When I got
my YouTube Like my YouTube Like summary for last year That
was my That was my highest thing on my channel We're tech
videos I was like No way.
No way.
Oh my gosh, this is ridiculous.
Sounds like you're a tech person.
I just like gimmick.
I just like a fun gimmick.
You try the aces phones.
I haven't.
I have very much calmed down.
you can business expensive
ninky the nerd i do i love a quirky gadget so much tech
people are like that but at the same time i don't want to be
associated with tech people because i know like so many of
them are very like okay but i am also like
they're very like like particular about what they like but I
think that's me too I'm
very like I want this in a phone and I want this in a phone
and oh this one has this feature so I won't get it but
you're not a jerk about it you don't think so should I I'm
not should I become where should I be be no more annoying
Oh.
My OSHA is a tech tuber.
I've just been watching stuff about phones a lot lately.
Tech unboxing hand cam streams.
When people are just like, how do you not know about this?
What's going on?
What's this internet stuff?
What's being talked about on Twitter?
It's because I'm watching videos of phone reviews.
I'm extremely I'm extremely Someone that before I buy Like a
phone or any sort of Electronic I will watch at least like
10-15 reviews on it You know what I mean Let's go to the
next area Slap me with a pack tail and call me lucky Look
who's wandered back into the shop Pull up a stool The
coffee's on and the minnows missed you I think you missed to
be rusty You're the same That's a careful purchase i try to
be very careful because usually it's like so much money
right for especially nowadays tech is even more expensive
especially for phones now because of the ram and everything
i love tech stuff have you considered buying one of those
new y2k flip phones just to have it i have
no hot dog hot dog how about the mochi phone wait i don't
know that one the mochi phone
you regret your current phone what is it right now i use the
the s23 ultra and honestly it's a great phone it's i've had
some issues with the stylus a little bit like
But, um...
Uh...
It's what I have.
You use the pen.
Oh my god, all the time.
I use the pen every day.
That's why I got the Ultra, because I wanted the pen.
I missed my One Plus 7 Pro.
That's the one I wanted.
I wanted the One Plus 7 Pro!
So bad!
I wanted it!
I wanted it worse!
than anything it was like my dream phone at the time oh i
wanted yeah
uh s25 ultra pen sucks no more bluetooth you know what i
don't use the bluetooth though yeah the pop-up camera oh so
cool you guys give me you guys give me you guys give me you
guys give me
I watched video after video after video of that phone and I
I was I've oh man I wanted it so bad I've never
been able to talk to anybody about that
Oh my god
I feel so seen right now
uh what was i doing oh yeah giving him money real nice of
you around these parts the biggest of the bunch earned the
name legendary catches oh it's just about the big guy that i
can't get they're mean they're stubborn and they ain't
coming easy you'll need more than your everyday geared land
one if you're hunting legends best be out there casting from
down to dark they show themselves certain times a day.
It's like I don't...
So if they ain't biting, kick back, and have a snooze.
Word around the lake is that big old legendary largemouth
bass has been stirring at dusk.
Yeah, we saw him.
We saw him.
That's all I'm spilling, friend.
I think maybe we need to get the next...
You know what?
I just thought about that.
Maybe we need to get the next...
Probably anyway.
The next fishing line for him.
Rod.
The next rod.
the timber jack I don't know if that would make him more
interested though I guess so maybe probably okay we'll save
for that
you can break your phone video addiction by falling down the
3D printer laser engraver rabbit hole I you know what has
stopped me from getting like a 3D printer is my inability to
model 3D stuff.
That's like my biggest obstacle.
I have to make the blender donut.
I have to blender...
Maybe I should do blender donut on stream.
You can download 3D models.
I know, but the song is fine.
The woodworking videos.
Yeah.
Blender donut.
Hmm.
Alright.
Let's go to the next area.
Since we haven't been to Golden Fork River yet.
Whoa!
Wow!
Whoa.
Oh.
I'm pressing the wrong button.
Oh!
Wait.
That's abandoned.
Dear Minky Tech Tips.
What do you think?
of the nothing phones i like the nothing phone oh my god did
you guys see the nothing headphones they look so clean
either the look of the nothing phone is so beautiful but
again i'm also a really big uh um camera person when it
comes to my a burbot my phones that's why i have all Samsung
so yeah let's go down yeah let's let's fish down here I love
phones with good refresh rate and camera mm-hmm and s26
ultra is also upping its refresh rate so but also it's gonna
be like $2,000 which is insanity it's somewhat the camera
yeah these guys are kind of cute these fish barbot what else
did we discover in here barbot creek chub short head red
horse that's a fish steelhead spinner bait wait do i have
any of these yet no we're getting into unknown territory
what was it again spinner spinner bait drop shot i think i
have yeah
have you seen the clicks communicator it gives me blackberry
vibes i don't think so oh wait i think that's that guy over
there oh wait wait oh they float so funny
let's see my moto OG stylus had lived like, Oh my gosh, I
had that too.
Oh my gosh, I found it today.
When I was, when I also found my essential phone and
everything.
I found that too.
I keep all my phones.
HTC M8.
I only had HTC once and I hated it so much that it turned me
off of Android.
I mean, this was like, I had an HTC Vive.
It was, and I, I hated it, like I said, I hated it so much.
I never wanted a, a, like I went to iPhone.
Because I, I was not a fan.
I don't think that he's coming over here.
Let's try and get this big boy on the right.
Come on.
Oh, come on.
Turn around.
Turn around!
Okay, maybe we could do this.
Back in the 1700s.
Exactly, exactly.
Yeah, this guy's big.
Come on.
Hi, Minto.
Hello!
Apple is doo-doo, though, but not back then.
Back then, the Android was pretty doo-doo.
This area looks nice.
I know, it's so cool.
Oh, yeah, yeah, grab it, grab it.
Yeah, grab it.
Yes.
Yes, sir.
Oh, I think this is our steely head guy.
Whoop.
Right now, I'm just trying to make some cash money, baby.
Come on.
Why is my...
There we go.
Showing us all your gadgets would be a great video or even
podcast topic.
I can't say, I don't know, a Phoebe and Vicky are so into
gadgets as well.
I just like me a gadget.
I don't know, Vicky maybe.
Mental tech tips.
I don't want to say I'm like a professional or anything.
It's just a special interest, I saw.
Let's see.
Spinner bait.
I have that, right?
Sorry, I can't remember.
I can't.
Spoon bait.
I can't remember all these.
Dang.
Names.
Dropshot.
Also for the rock bash.
We'll just dropshot again then.
Whoops.
There we go.
Ghost gotta have hobbies.
That's the thing.
I have many hobbies.
And you know what?
Hobbies are so expensive.
Hobbies are expensive.
Expensive.
Come on, come on.
I know you're interested.
They are.
Yeah.
Especially, like, you know, I'm into idols.
Idols are always releasing merch.
I had to stop myself from getting a check-e yesterday
because I was like...
I would have to...
Like, do the shipping for just a check-e.
And it would be so expensive!
Yeah, instruments are very expensive.
Yeah, instruments are so expensive.
Did you have a Kindle?
No, actually, I did not have a Kindle.
Wait, I thought I had the right guy.
What am I looking for?
Rock Bash.
I was looking at the wrong guy, my bad.
Please move.
Developing an idle phone.
yeah
easy I think Pokemon card collecting is a good example of an
expensive hobby nowadays Pokemon card collecting is crazy
there's nothing worse than when a hobby that's one thing
some hobbies never will get uh targeted by scalpers but when
a hobby does get targeted by scalpers it's just so oh it's
so disheartening
archery is surprisingly expensive too I think I mean certain
sports yeah will probably be pretty expensive come on come
on the triple the triple dipper yes
I blame Jake Paul I think it is his fault though I think it
is like actually a good portion of him is the reason why the
Pokemon card thing exploded the way it did
or Logan I cannot remember the brothers so glad I share a
special interest with my kamiyoshi thank you for being
yourself veto thank you So happy, so happy.
Let's go over somewhere.
Those darn corporate AI enthusiasts have destroyed my RAM
collecting on me.
RIP to everybody who collected RAM.
Just for the pretty colors.
Oh, I squail.
Why did you share that specific video in your dream?
worst wait have i saw okay i've seen everything in this area
cocoa but
if you have a hobby and it hasn't been i mean obviously some
hobbies will sometimes be taken over i don't i don't mean
like that like it's really just scalpers that will ruin a
hobby
it sucks my minto metal gear dream what is that you're
dreaming about me
it's a good thing i'm a rem fed how much this one is what
400 there you are place ain't the same without your boots on
the floor oh he hasn't unlocked a new place yet oh wait here
we go spinner bait i'll grab that awesome awesome awesome
400 yeah okay let's go let's go grab the other guys we
haven't gotten yet which i think literally oh we need spoon
bait too i guess we don't because we caught two without it.
Spinner bait.
Okay, perfect.
Are these, for anybody that knows fishing, are these like
real lures?
Are they just funky names for the game?
There it is.
They are real?
Wait, that's so fun!
That is pretty fun.
Turn around, turn around, turn around, turn around, turn
around, turn around, oh, turn around, oh, I didn't want the
tiny guy, but that's alright.
We'll take what we can get.
The steel head.
Works for anything if you believe.
Anything can be spspsps.
Wait, I think I need to throw.
There's nothing here.
What's the other guy I'm trying to fish for?
Is anybody else when I fish in this game?
Like, do you have like...
You feel like you have the need to hold your breath?
I feel like I'm under the water.
And I feel like I need to hold my breath.
Is it just me?
We need the creek chub!
Where's that guy?
Oh, I think these are the... Okay, these are guys.
These are guys right here.
Come here, Bituber.
I'm here.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes.
You run.
I had!
What were they fishing for?
The chub.
Wait, where'd they go?
Where'd they go?
Wait, wait, wait.
There's a big...
Wait, they're right there!
Oh my gosh.
They're finicky.
I did equip the new thing, right?
The new lure.
They're not interested even a little bit.
Shaking the Metal Gear bag loudly like dog food.
Yeah, that'll work.
That will actually work.
Oh, wait.
Turn around, please.
Thank you.
How polite.
Oh, yeah.
I know my cats um sometimes I have sometimes their wet food
is like in a can right and so I have to get my tuna now in
the pouches because if I well I don't have to but if I open
a can of tuna they will be like all over me and trying to
get it you know would you do it for a calorie baby pinky
Please!
Come on!
My dog is the same way.
Chudu?
Oh, my cats go insane over the chudu.
I mean, I think any cat would go insane over the chudu.
Yay!
We got him!
nice yeah tire him out he's tiring me out wait so which one
of these little this creek chubs where are you
you need the smaller rod oh that makes so much sense you
know what i did think about that otherwise they get too
scared oh oh oh oh come on
It is the right one, right?
Oh, yeah, we got a bider.
Yay!
Teeny baby.
Teeny tiny baby.
All right.
Why, though, some of these, like...
You see how there's X's and then there's the slashes?
I wonder what that means.
Hmm.
It means all sizes.
So if I get an X, that means I caught both sizes.
Ah, I see.
Oh my god.
Holy!
I guess he's our legend.
Maybe.
Ah.
I see, I see, I see.
He's so small.
Wait, um, it's the drop shot, right?
I think.
No, well, thank you so much for that one, I kept it.
Thank you!
Boorbot.
Spoon bait.
Spoon.
We'll try to have a spoon bait.
So we can try and get a big boy.
Ha!
How long have I been playing this game for?
Oh, three and a half hours?
Cool.
I'm telling you, it's these the fishing games, they really
get me.
Let's see, though.
Let's try and go back to see if we can get to the next area.
We'll just try to discover a bunch of areas.
Minto fishing yapping flow state.
We love fishing.
No, we could get the next rod!
That cooler better be heavy or we're fine.
Gimme!
Ah yeah!
Timber Jack!
Let's go!
You have something to say?
Thanks, bud.
Thanks for playing this and showing us your fishing prowess.
Of course!
Halled in a big steelhead, did you?
Thing must have fought like a wolverine on a bad day.
Got this new rod in, too.
Good for hauling more like it.
The freshwater kind, anyway.
Or chucking bait out way deep.
More?
Oh, blue baitcaster.
Wow, she's a beaut.
Wait, so it also...
Wow, what's the difference between, like, a mono and a
braid?
I guess this one would be better with the upgrades, because
this one is...
Oh, okay, okay.
Tougher line.
Oh, I get it, I get it.
Okay, so it's like single string versus like braided string.
Oh, interesting, interesting, interesting.
I'm actually learning about fishing.
This is crazy.
That's so fun.
Wait, this is so awesome.
Wait, this is so fun.
Okay.
I do have this game on my list of like you know when I'm
when I travel to have this game to play this game you know
what I mean while I'm out and about so it might be like kind
of a I don't play it for a while but it's probably because
I'm saving it for when I'm like on my travel setup you know
what I mean this game gets a lot of things right you could
tell that like the who made it like knew their stuff which
is really fun yeah
gaming abroad first stream i've caught and i love that this
is the chilly chilly sea up and fish stream thank you thanks
for sticking around i'm glad you liked it thank you thank
you thank you
you can tell that the person who made it is a fish Yeah.
This is, but then I feel like they would punish you for
fishing.
This is, this is, it would be, because this is like fishing
propaganda.
They would be like, no, we have to make it where you go
fishing and bad things happen.
Just notice the scene page has an Asian themed DLC for June.
Hope it gives you a game.
Wait, hope you give a game.
Hope you give the game another shot when it comes out.
Wait, oh it's not out yet.
saw that too but the there's the supporter pack which gives
you more animals
and then
wait I'm going to the store page I'm sorry if you hear oh
sorry you can hear the game yeah it came out June of last
year so it's kind of but it's been doing like very
consistent updates which is really cool like they did a
winter update and they did like the fall update and oh yeah
I see it Eastern winds.
Wow!
Wait, it's not out yet?
Oh yeah, June 20, 26.
Good day, Minto.
I passed JLPT N3 today.
Ombedito!
Oh my gosh.
Congratulations!
I...
JLPT stresses me out.
I'm not like a test taker.
I'm not the test taker type.
It'll scare me.
Congrats!
That's so awesome!
Yeah.
What level do I think of it?
Oh, sorry.
Probably around N3.
I'm just conversational enough to get me around.
The N3 to N2 hurdle is like...
It's really hard.
because especially like you know when you learn a language
and you are able to be conversational then you're like oh
well I don't need to it's it's hard to one like find the
motivation to at least for me to find the motivation to keep
pushing and then also like it's it the the the especially
especially if we're like Japanese when you go from like you
know normal keigo normal like uh polite speech to like ultra
polite speech and you're like oh man it's like such a the n3
to n2 is like crazy
it's like a huge huge difficulty spike hyper formal yeah
It's like just keigo, like, you know, you have like, you
have casual, basic, and keigo.
No, there's like layers of keigo.
There's like, there's like at least five ways to say one
thing.
So it's just like, oh my God.
Kanji.
Yeah, kanji is.
Yeah, English doesn't have polite speak.
Exactly.
I mean, it does, but it doesn't at the same time, you know,
like.
People, if you're too polite, even in a business situation,
people think you're being kind of weird.
So it's like, when do we even use the ultra polite speak
anymore?
Like, people are going to be like, yo, you're too uptight.
Come on.
We're just having a business meeting.
We're chill.
In emails.
We just have sir and madam.
Oh, ma'am.
official document.
I guess that's true, yeah.
But yeah.
Keep, keep.
It's just like anything, though, guys.
You just got to keep, keep at it.
I just got to keep, keep at it.
Sir, please stop padding out your sentence.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I have a word count, a minimum word count that I need for
this essay.
So...
Yes, I will say the thing that I need to say in the longest
way that I can possibly say it.
Saita!
No!
It is, but you can do it.
I think I will end it here, though, guys.
Sorry.
I got sleepy all sudden.
I think I will call it...
Wait, no, before we call it here, We got that big...
We got that big, that big one.
Let's try it on this guy.
I just want to see if he bites.
Have a good... Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Switch to...
Timberjack.
And then it was...
I think it was just a brown trout, so crankbait.
Big, big crankbait.
Yeah.
Whip.
Ha!
La la la la la.
Sinking to the bottom of the lake.
Nope.
I'm not far enough.
Keep it going.
Oh my gosh, there's a beaver right next.
to me.
I'm like snow white.
These animals have no fear.
Okay.
Like here?
Ah!
Yeah.
Unless it's...
Unless we have to do dusk.
Unless he's not.
Oh,
I think I lost him.
I lost him.
Oh!
He grabbed!
It was our fishing rod.
Ha ha ha ha.
I will get you.
Oh.
Look at how I'll get you.
Some slack, some slack.
Come back my way, come back my way.
Yes.
They're so energized, so ganky.
your dog is swimming that's not my dog it's a beaver
nice yeah they're feisty they're feisty this is my dog this
is my dog
beavers are so funny just creating dams like that what did
they what did they see in a past like in the past that made
them evolve to where they needed to create dams big aquatic
dogs yeah going to watch iron lung right now bye captain
tell me how it is oh my gosh i want to go see it so bad
yippee all right guys i will call it here though thank you
so much for joining me for a cast and chill.
We did cast and we did chill.
So it was a lot, a lot of fun.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Um, yeah.
Chill stream today.
Well, tomorrow will be a little more hectic, so I wanted
something pretty chill today.
Um, but yeah.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, to be tall.
Dorko, thank you so much for the peek.
Caught us hook, line, and sinker.
You'll snag us next time too.
Good night, Winto.
Good night.
J-DON!
OCHO-OCHO!
OCHO!
Frag me, thank you!
Thanks for the comfort for sharing.
Thank you for the pink!
OCHO, Winto!
OCHO, OCHO Winto!
OCHO Winto!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.